hi I'm Eric Voss and the vengers in
games complicated story line delivers
thrilling callbacks MCU past but also
leaves us wondering about the mysteries
of who knew what when they knew it and
why fictional time travelers don't
salute their own asses more often one of
the most cryptic scenes in avengers
endgame centred around the ancient one
her majesty Tilda Swinton Hulk slash
Banner convinces the ancient one to give
him the time stone by referencing Doctor
Strange and his mysterious strategy to
surrender this stone to Thanos speech in
one's eyes went wide and behind
Swinton's divine soul piercing stare she
starts to piece together the
hypothetical future that strange hinted
at and have been anymore the one series
of events in which they win now we all
saw this victory in endgame but but re
watching the film you can actually
determine the precise elements of
Stephen Strange's vision and how that
explains all of his behavior and the
ancient wants behavior throughout the
events of endgame and Infinity Ward but
before we begin to break this down quick
announcement to any Game of Thrones fans
living in the New York area to join us
for a live finale watch Part II and
after show this Sunday May 19th details
in the description below ok let's start
by reexamining the interaction between
the ancient one and banner when he first
arrives looking for strange she responds
you're about five years too early
this means the ancient one has used the
time stone to appear into the future and
she knows that a surgeon named Stephen
strange will become the next sorcerer
supreme by the way this actually
establishes why Hydra listed Stephen
strange who is still a mere surgeon as a
target as early as 2014 with sitwell's
line and Winter Soldier how did he know
Stephen strange would this is 2014
Stephen truth was still like performing
surgery and rocking out to jams but with
the Ancient Ones line if Sorcerer's
around the world knew to keep their eyes
on this hotshot surgeon it does kind of
make sense that Hydra might see him as a
potential threat okay anyway being
ancient one knocks out Bruce banners
astral projection and says let's start
over shall we
and some sly wordplay by the ancient one
here because the Avengers whole time
iced is essentially an attempt to start
over after their timeline explanation
the ancient one turns
when banner says that strange gave away
the time stone to Thanos willingly you
mean he will what banner says maybe
strange made a mistake and the ancient
one says or I did
she says strange is meant to be the best
of us and agrees with banner that he
must have given Thanos the stone for a
reason now the mistake that the ancient
one is referring to was a mistake to
doubt banner but also could be her
initial failing to perceive how much
more juice dr. strange could one day
ring out of this time stone using his
natural photographic memory to see
various permutations that no one else
ever could so let's take the ancient
ones words here and apply them to dr.
Strange's actions knowing what we now
know from in gain what was the exact
plan that he foresaw so in infinity war
strange looks ahead to 14 million 605
ultimate futures he had to look at so
many because he was probably first
looking at options that didn't require
Thanos to initially win and half of them
including strange himself to dust away
but eventually he realized that for them
to win the long game the infinity war
they have to lose this battle because
when Thanos first shows up in infinity
war he already has two stones according
to ebony maan no one else in existence
had accomplished that much so that's why
Thanos removed his armor from that point
forward with these two gathering the
remaining stones was more of a spiritual
quest tough slow march to destiny so
that's why strange surrendered the time
stone the snap was unavoidable at that
point this Thanos was inevitable but
strange also knew that the snap would
set the stage perfectly for a comeback
Scott Lang would be trapped in the
quantum realm at the time of the snap
staying there until 5 years of the
outside world past teaching Scott about
the quantum realms connection to
time-travel this five-year period also
gave Tony Stark time to run various
mobius strip simulations so that they
combined surviving Avengers could
orchestrate this time heist strange also
likely new banners specific role in this
timeline it's actually kind of funny
when you've rewatch the infinity war
sanctum scene strange actually witnessed
his banners timeline confusion what's
her timeline no telling maybe that was
just a throwaway line but it is
interesting that the ancient one leaves
by telling him these words I'm counting
on you Bruce we all are so strange could
have foreseen this moment and knew that
banner needed to feel this burden so
that later banner would step forward to
wear Starks new gauntlet to snap
everyone back he says it's like I was
made for this Hulk green everyone back
sets the stage for a battle that
stranged new team Avengers could win an
infinity war the Avengers were still
divided spread out playing defense to
catch up to a Thanos who was already way
ahead of them with the stones but now in
endgame strains brought the Avengers
together in a rematch on a more even
playing field with the Avengers United
the guardians of the galaxy reunited
along with a ton of backup from other
sorcerers as Guardians wakandans
Ravagers
Captain Marvel Howard the Duck is there
they're all motivated by the sting of
defeat
facing the Thanos before you got any of
the stones or met any of these
characters
he tells Scarlet Witch I have no idea
who you are and that's a huge advantage
for the Avengers because for them this
is a rematch but for Thanos this is
round 1 of a fight with people he
doesn't know but most importantly in dr.
Strange's plan he knows it will have to
end with Tony Stark sacrificing himself
only Stark's Iron Man nanotech armor
could absorb the stones off Thanos his
hands strange signals this final move to
start by holding up one finger
deliberately referencing their
conversation in infinity war
how many rule in one rewatching it's
interesting to see how Cumberbatch
played that moment he looked at Stark
with this grave expression choking up
with some emotion in that moment strange
new what Stark would later have to do to
cross the goal line
and really everything strange told Stark
was a similar clue earlier in this
endgame battle strange told him that if
the told Stark whether this was the
winning timeline or not it wouldn't
happen and an infinity war he apologized
to stark saying this was the only way
and we're in the endgame now endgame is
the phase in chess when you begin to
make key strategic sacrifices to box
your opponent into checkmate and streams
apologize because he foresaw Tony having
to give up his life he didn't want to
tell Stark that directly because he
didn't want to potentially bias him
against fulfilling this destiny so there
you have it the one at a 14 million 605
alternate futures in which the Avengers
be
danos required an initial Thanos victory
Scott Lang and Tony Stark figuring out
time travel straight his old mentor
helping banner get to a place to snap
everyone back a united front against a
stone less Thanos and the sacrifice
played by stark and Howard the Duck true
MVP comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on instagram and
twitter at EA boss subscribe to new rock
stars on youtube and again if you're a
Game of Thrones fan in the New York area
check out our live finale watch party
and after show this Sunday May 19th
details in the description below thank
you for joining me and ooh still image
of ancient one Tilda Swinton just winked
at me so I got to change my pants
[Music]